eine muh eine mäh reine täter oder eine
tut gut einordnen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
also wir alleine zwei weihnachtslieder
ausgewählt philipp hat zwei
weihnachtslieder genommen die er
wahnsinnig gerne habe und er sie uns
jetzt vor dann fängt sofort an hierbei
mäßig zu schimpfen ich bin erster oft
ich mag auch diese weihnachten denn hört
man einfach jedes jahr und es ist so ein
bisschen heimat aber gleichzeitig finde
ich ihnen ganz scheußlich verstehe ich
alles nicht ich finde einfach es ist
eine herrliche atmosphärische
verdichtung von weihnachten wenn man das
video können sie das video was in der
schweiz gedreht wurden
[Musik]
ein mann der sich versteckt aber du hast
mich zerrissen ja das ist klingt
ziemlich kannst du dir und deiner seele
aus eis ich singe immer mit aber ich
habe mir noch nie gedanken über den text
gemacht in wirklichkeit das rabbinat
liebeslied und zufällig zu weihnachten
und heißt halt betonung enttäuschte
liebe man darf nicht so lange darüber
reden so zerstört man es was haben ganz
viele leute gesungen aber niemand so
schön wie sie es ist eigentlich ein
weihnachtslied ohne jedes klischee von
weihnachten zu bedienen und es ist auch
ein
ja du hast recht man wird ja so darauf
gedrillt dass man diesen deal mit dem
weihnachtsmann macht man es brav und
dann gibt's was und dass dieses lied
sitzt diesen fortgang der verhandlung
irgendwie fort und sagt nicht nur war
ich brav und deswegen will ich ein tobel
und eine platin gelang sondern ich werde
auch nächstes jahr braucht sein unter
der voraussetzung dass ich noch einige
andere sachen bekommen eigentlich ein
konsum liegt aber auf eine ganz hübsch
aber ich finde es ist auch recht
subversiv mit zeilen wie ich glaube
wirklich an dich mal sie hat mich
glaubst sehe ich meine die frage stellt
ja den weihnachtsmann eigentlich auch
keiner ja es war hitlers lieblingslied
zu weihnachten oder reese kind ungefähr
so wenn also das ist ja wirklich
[Musik]
grauenhaft und das lustige daran ist
dass es ja auch so ein bisschen dann das
weihnachtliche kaputt sind ja und immer
noch nicht fassen kann dass genau
vorstellen wie man damit die
narreneltern ich weiß ich bin sowas von
nicht feierliche hauptraum branche boomt
alles war es hat alles bei nacht licht
[Musik]
das ist einfach etwas was ich sehr gerne
singe und hörer zum erst mal sehe ich
diesen vers in den herzen ist zwar still
schweighofer und harm das ist ja zauber
streitet ihr euch zu weihnachten auch
wenn wir streiten uns nie wieso auch er
streitet sich den beiden bitte noch
streiten sie sich doch einfach nicht
jemand zu weihnachten mit seiner ganzen
familie das kann auch einfach nicht sein
ich bin froh dass wir das geklärt haben
die man streitet sich zu weihnachten ich
liebe weihnachten ich auch liebe man
nicht weihnachten ist das schönste fest
[Musik]